[Music]
if you if you consider the fact that
we'll expect this to go let's start them
starting with black is not be they are
professor played over and false let's
buy something else the Trump is an early
indication that I'm not going to be
getting very many theoretical
discussions today usually ago
III scare but then I was maybe thinking
that anyway okay see this setup anyway
are three and ninety issue and I try to
do this inside kind of somewhat
surprised by by the Trump and then I
tend to see six still quite said about
my position but [ __ ] puzzling once
again if this is the Disco's if we can
call them shows why deviate from it just
because I didn't little six I don't get
that
okay the black position here is I mean
it's solid but passive and not it's
probably and then the question is I
figure out if I can well they're Safari
version event Queen Piper's pieces six
think we night for um probably rather
plays rugby one just to keep some
flexibility then goes from the Queen
exchange and otherwise for was very
logical someone see the short if I can
stop it I shall probably be stopping it
okay so I have some other ideas like on
Queen c1 then rupee three I guess
something like something along the lines
of Justice
three is very playable for him what he
is doing this course is also perfectly
natural but I do create a threat of one
here and I could also maybe consider
going CB v CB v LC 8 next move p6 quite
nice for me I thought I was going to be
a sort of a lot of i7 is tempting but
then much depends on whether he can
actually play beat actually six here
because I think CB 5 next movement is
quite interesting it's gonna play Bishop
e6 like to protect that point if I gotta
see one he goes would be a teammate a
Cobra da file so I'm gonna oh I almost
wonder there are 193 but bc 6 with your
idea he's an actual 92 i say i think is
blue but it's very very risky for him
because we are play this is the line i
was trying to calculate yeah you should
go on you could take only four yeah I
missed that that's kind of relevant
unfortunately yeah I missed I missed
Bishop takes e4 that's something very
very get something uc3m and then play d5
very happy a large amount of trouble
here despite a nice looking bishop under
pressure it's natural it's still not a
great position at least we'll have a
nice little for like well maybe I can do
the arm problem tending or you sharpen
the position up a little bit if he goes
rupee for its movement very sweet
endless stupid square for the rope you
can go rookie maybe not that stupid
though because the b6 bone is very very
weak once again yeah it is not a threat
because of the four I have some tactical
resources there yeah King f8 he's tricky
like if he picks one is no place for
in the end but if I take on on p6 twice
it's gonna have bishop tasty for and the
idea of King f8 obviously use and by
rank checkmate now I can take them b6 no
Brooke yeah yeah I thought I have
something I need service work yeah yeah
not wandering knight Knight d7 check led
to King h8 obviously are a little